Reactome is a free, manually curated knowledge
base that provides a user-friendly platform to
access and analyse information on
molecular mechanisms of reactions
and pathways. It provides highly detailed pathway
diagrams of molecular processes and descriptions,
available via the Reactome website and to download
in standard formats such as BioPax and SBML.
The basic unit of Reactome is a reaction, which is
defined as any molecular event; including binding,
phosphorylation, biochemical catalysis, molecular
transport and spontaneous molecular events.
These reactions can involve any biological
molecule, but are typically proteins and
small molecules (chemical compounds).
A pathway is defined as a series of connected
reactions, with each individual reaction
considered as a single step in the pathway.
These are represented as pathways
in detailed molecular diagrams.
Examples of pathways include immune system
signalling, the cell cycle and apoptosis.
In Reactome, we create pathways
using reactions as building blocks.
Reactions are interconnected based on biological
relevance resulting in the formation of pathways.
The key aspects of Reactome content are quality
and attribution. Pathways are written by expert
biologists and independently peer-reviewed
before being included in the database.
Reactions always cite scientific literature that
experimentally verifies the described event.
These manually curated human pathways
are used as templates to computationally
infer equivalent pathways in other species,
including most commonly used model organisms.
High-throughput technologies allow researchers
to identify gene regulation markers and determine
gene expression, protein and metabolite levels
for many thousands of molecules in a single
experiment, generating huge amounts of data.
Interpreting these data requires an understanding
of the connections between these molecules.
An effective way to do this is to integrate
experimental information with well-annotated
established pathway data. Reactome fulfils this
need by providing free access to detailed pathways
combined with analytical tools. Reactome includes
tools for analysing the pathway context of your
data, mapping expression or other quantitative
data onto pathways or extending pathways
with interactions from external databases.
There are two ways to access the Analysis
submission form. Either clicking the
Analyse Data button on the homepage or using the
Analysis button on the Pathway Browser header bar.
Upon clicking the Analyze Data, an
interface pops out where you can submit
your data and perform various analyses.
The tabs on the left of this interface
indicate the different types of analyses:
• Analyse gene list: pathway enrichment
analysis (user input required)
• Analyse gene expression:
gene enrichment analysis (user input required)
• Species Comparison: compare human pathways
with other species
• Tissue Distribution:
compare pathways in various tissue types
You can select the analysis you want to perform,
paste in or browse for a file containing
your data, or use an example data set.